i was watching your show last night and
i think the best way to indicate how
great this show really is is
the word god damn it frank it's my
favorite line because
i kind of that sums up this whole show i
mean
for you to create and write this show
together is it slightly
loosely based on your own lives
how dare you either confirm nor deny
[Laughter]
that um no no no none of the events in
the show
you know there are maybe uh certain kind
of
dramatic things i suppose uh you know
like
uh don't tell me to cut i gotta shut up
right now
no but you know staying at home too long
kind of having a girlfriend that you
can't get over
you know um certain things like that
resonate with with most people or a lot
of people
um but no i think all the humor just
came from myself and donald and michael
maloney are called writers just kind of
sitting around and trying to make each
other laugh i think that was the main
thing
um so yeah and so
what does your parents think of the show
um well dad's in it so hopefully that's
an indication that he was comfortable
enough with us to
to kind of um and he had seen some of
the stuff we had shot and all the rest
before he came to set so he's in the
last episode
where everything sort of comes to a head
and he did an amazing job he's very very
funny in it
and ma'am uh has had this line all the
way through she said if anyone asked
what i think of the show
uh tell them i said it's filthy but i'm
very proud of your vote
no that's how mom feels about it it
weirdly you never know what's going to
make mom laugh
but she fell around yes so we were
delighted to give her a reason to laugh
you guys must have so much fun creating
this show i mean how do you even keep a
straight face when you're delivering the
lines and
the relationship between frank and
doofus the name doof is first of all but
how was it for you to shoot it it was
great it was great you know the the uh
there wasn't that much corpsing really
apart from episode one
at the wake haha yes
and you just don't let anyone down i
mean there were a couple of moments
myself
donald we're quite close contact looking
at each other and it's the end of the
day
and we're both quite tired and we're
about looking at the emptiness in each
other's eyes um
and we're going to laugh a little bit
but it was kind of uh
you know and the show looks really
beautiful as well and that takes time to
capture with the camera
so you know your responsibility to other
people you can't just
be messing around so i think we were
pretty good at putting
manners on each other with regards to
laughing maybe i'm wrong don't maybe i'm
wrong
maybe not all the way through it
it's just made up as you're going yeah
no you're talking about the landscape is
you know the fact that you guys got to
shoot this in dublin i mean how excited
are you for the people of dublin
to watch this show i would say more
scared
i mean you know you're always nervous
about a hometown crowd but
um no i i think it's going to be very
interesting to see how people at home
respond to it you know because
it's very recognizable in one way out
the area where we shot and everything
but it's also a version of that place i
mean we talked for a while that maybe
calling the hometown something different
than what we did because it's not
exactly that obviously and the people
who populate it are not exactly that
but i hope it makes people laugh you
know like that's all we care about is
swept up in the story then we'll feel
we've done a good job so fingers crossed
that's the way to
yeah you're not prepared for some of the
dark comedy i was watching with my kids
and my kids you gotta leave like you
cannot listen to it
or watch any of this how old are your
kids
they're thirteen she's just up and she
saw a derriere and i was like okay
you need to go but you know i wasn't
ready for that but you know the fact it
makes you think also
uh being at home i was at home until i
was in university but
did you think at this point in your
career you would be here at this moment
in your lives
i mean you're 33 brienne so i mean do
you feel that this is a momentous moment
in your life
yeah but i never i never thought i'd be
able to do something like this
uh that's credit to donald and michael i
never
helped us make the show but um
you know like life does go by very
quickly and and
i still feel like i'm 25 26 or whatever
so
in terms of what frank's going through
uh it's relatable in some ways
or in in that particular way and no
other way whatsoever
just to be absolutely clear about that
um
but yeah he's kind of blinked and he's
gotten older and everyone's moved on a
prayer for him
i think that is kind of relatable in a
way you know
and you reference kevin costner and his
movies so
what is your favorite kevin costner
movie
i i love tin cup i absolutely love tin
cup
and i don't i mean i i don't think it's
like in terms of like the full-on
yeah serious some of his other stuff i
know that it's not quite that but
there's a charm about tin cup that i
really remember uh really remember
enjoying
um kevin costner was in 10 cup right i
mean it doesn't be so funny
have i seen that i don't know if i've
seen it he's definitely in cook there's
a bit where he
pretends to he's he's playing golf in it
and he tries to hit a sand wedge but
with a uh
with a with like a a shovel so there you
go there's an element of got it
okay i know what you're talking about
now yes what did you think i was saying
oh is it the axe i'm throwing it off
sorry
tin
[Laughter]
i can't remember the name we did a
western with woody harrelson that was on
netflix a couple years ago
and he just played a very classic you
know like the stoic
american lawman and actually nailed it
uh
very hard things you know to do as an
actor it's only certain
only certain actors that can do that i
thought like he's greater than that uh
so yeah we like kevin costner and we
need to talk he's moving
like yeah the old the old kind of type
or something like that like
he's a proper movie well he'll need to
be on your show one day that's for sure
if you go to the next season i i hope
so and uh you just never know you may
show up
if frank meets kevin costner i think
that the universe will implode
i don't know i don't think that's like
you know two black holes colliding i'm
not sure that it would totally make
sense
physics would stop operating properly oh
thanks for making me laugh the show is
brilliant congratulations to the both of
you
thank you thanks everyone thanks emily
you